[Aplausos]
ora esta mal usado como fizeram descer
do primeiro interveniente o único homem
num no encontro terex aquelas mulheres
eu vou tentar compensar lá falando
basicamente de mulheres precisamente o
que não é muito difícil porque na
verdade eu vivo odiado delas em casa mas
também ao longo de toda a minha vida é
que os homens que fazem parte da minha
vida também normalmente não estavam lá
muito presente
aliás esse é um traço que estava roxo
trazer aqui e vou explicar um pouco um
traço que caracterize a comunidade onde
vai cuidar das caxinas
eu diria que elas uma palavra com muito
significado dessa palavra ao vencia a
ausência da mãe
reparem é neste caso pode ser preso se
sentida de várias formas
pode ser a ausência dos homens
precisamente pode ser a própria ausência
de uma identidade administrativa
nada que é aqui é o lugar não é uma
freguesia numa cidade concentra em si
uma tal sociológica
logicamente falando o facto de as
pessoas ficarem uma atividade principal
que é pesca e depois vocês perguntou
assim a pesca assim mas eu fui lá ter a
praia é um lugar e não viu um único
barco até os barcos como os homens que
estão ausentes estão por esse país fora
estão nos estrangeiros estão por aí mas
pouco lá é que esses traços de ausência
temos que acrescentar ainda uma outra
que a ausência provocada por morte
sempre muito para
o evento é para quem vive do mar e que a
idéia é sobrecarregada
algumas vezes com o facto de si mesmo
mar nem sequer nos devolver os corpos
daqueles que perdemos e neste múltiplos
traços nestas múltiplas formas de
encarar a ausência é quem sobra o que
sobra são as mulheres e por isso que
elas são assim tão importante na minha
vida e naquela comunidade eu começava
por apresentar vos uma mãe não encontrei
melhor parceiro que olhar pra casa seria
bastante a minha mãe e minha mãe aqui
por uma questão muito simples está bem
documentada naquela frase foi com ela
que o prende até mesmo o mago é minha
primeira experiência com o mar ou melhor
experiência que eu lembro é não tem a
ver como ir à praia com o mergulho nada
disso nada traumático é uma coisa
diferente eu estava numa sala da aula
com os meus amigos com a minha
professora mulher gosta e vira uma
funcionária e ovar dois colegas meus
embora porque tinha morrido o pai
naquela noite naquela mulher no
naufrágio
lembro em uma malga memórias que na
sessão da qual dia ou não mas nessa
noite com o mau tempo de como é habitual
acontecer maravilhas marcos sentir o
vento nas persianas viu entrar no quarto
praticamente e de ouvir no quarto ao
lado da minha mãe rezar pra nós crianças
aumentou brincamos jogamos a bola era
também esse momento perigoso e pode
roubar o melhor que temos no mundo
minha mãe tem outra característica a no
território de onde eu venho à força
física a capacidade física é e para
valorizada
o que é normal porque as pessoas
nasceram para trabalhar num evento
e ela viu se a braços com um filho
primogênito que tem uma deficiência
física que o impediria a partir de ser
pescador como os outros
na verdade ela teve essa capacidade
dessa grandeza de não proteger e
garantir as oportunidades suficientes
para ter um percurso que na verdade mas
o que ela o próprio imaginaríamos quando
ana porque tem muito mais magro do que
seria suposto a a partida e por isso que
eu estou aqui te vai hoje é passava
apresentadas uma outra pessoa é minha
tia-avó uma das minhas tias avós têm
algumas ainda vivas
esta minha tia avó é neta de um herói
vai o herói salva vidas é mas pra mim
basicamente eu resumiria a esta senhora
olívia anúncio livro - é uma palavra um
sorriso porque é que é tão importante um
sorriso que é uma coisa que todos nós
sabemos fazer na nossa vida no momento
qualquer maior funcionário é que esta
senhora com muitas outras teria muitos
motivos para não sorrir foi retirada
será a escola trabalhou duro em cima
mente enfrenta a casa onde vive no porto
de pesca da póvoa do varzim desde
criança quando casou de rosário casar
com o cursor uma experiência aqui hoje
muitas pessoas vivem mas teve coragem de
responder essa acção duas formas
primeiro acabando com ela
debussy anos numa altura em que isso não
era uma coisa futuramente normal até
porque a música popular com seus
clientes em que vive no mar e rola na
areia
bato nela quando quer
mas a outra passou isso e além disso
durante toda a sua vida nos todas sempre
que encontrei ela fez sempre questão de
tentar mostrar que tentava ser feliz a
pesar das adversidades todas por que
passou
e um filme uma imagem que fica no meu
álbum de família dessa felicidade eu
encontro nesta fotografia no arquivo
pessoal é que se repete várias vezes em
cada casamento da família é é a minha
teoria milhas obrigavam sempre a fazer
uma fotografia com ela a dançar nos dois
foi talvez a primeira pessoa que me
lembro é conseguir fazer ultrapassar a
minha deficiência e hotéis lançar um
pouco na minha vida mas com ela se
encontrasse hoje se ela hoje tivesse
pernas já não têm para lançar tenho
certeza que andaríamos uns pezinhos
doença e trago então uma outra mulher
outro que a vó minha tia anterior fez
aliás fez 82 esta fez anos há pouco fez
93 está prevista a cama conforme você vê
ele está muito bem de seu uso e capaz de
nos contar toda uma vida cheia também
experiências marcantes
não vou trazer que um aspecto da vida
dela que quase 1.5 dci significativo
como estas pessoas tenham que usar
estratégias mais impensáveis para
sobreviver para viver é minha tia-avó do
abel é ela e seu marido não vai falhar
como muitas mulheres daquela território
tem uns maridos na pesca do bacalhau
seis meses ausente está e ela tinha que
trabalhar também fazer outras coisas
entre as várias coisas que fazia era
será que sair a mãe numa altura em que
ela tinha um dos filhos muito pequeno
bebê praticamente colo a gatinhar ela
tinha que ir trabalhar para o fracasso e
onildo várias vezes se aproximava se da
beira mar e corria risco de morrer
afogado pois ela não teve mais que por
ano
abrir uma cova e entregá lo até o
pescoço e vocês disse chamei porque são
menores
diríamos nós hoje não é é bom que não
avaliamos os atos segundo o padrão atual
das nossas vidas
o estado social é inexistente neste
tempo em que isso aconteceu a 50 60 70
anos mas talvez tentaremos talvez nunca
são gênios e se ela não fosse trabalhar
só não ganhasse dinheiro provavelmente
aquela que aquelas crianças como outras
não é o tempo acabariam enterradas na
mesma provavelmente enterradas porque
estavam mortas nem e em frente
deixávamos aqui uma outra pessoa mais
nova como a experiência mais
contemporânea é é uma prima do pai ao
vila flor é que traga o que pra uma
questão muito particular e que ao mesmo
tempo comum naquela comunidade
há três décadas mais ou menos ao vira
pra ver o marido um irmão e toda a
tripulação do barco da família no
naufrágio
quando isso aconteceu ela tinha três
filhos
um era jovem os outros dois eram ainda
crianças e ela como outras pessoas e
nada do que estou a contar é exclusivo
destas pessoas
ela basicamente ultrapassou tudo aqui o
eventou uma família retomou o negócio
portanto com uma nova embarcação e na
água contou com o facto de filho mais
novo acaba por se tornar agora mais
recentemente pescador também e mestra
daquela embarcação ela aos tempos numa
entrevista na televisão com sawa que não
gosta da praia vai por internet que nos
dentes gostam do mar claro mas quando
vai sempre sempre um pouco mal porque
tem quem tripular o mar é procurar na
verdade nunca devolveu marido
e claro quando se ouve isso pouco mais
há a dizer e agora apresentamos a
madrinha da usina
chamamos ele também queria minha avó já
está vivo e volto a família mais próxima
à minha avó por uma questão muito
importante
estou aqui porque o mais regionalista
tem uma relação muito intensa com a
minha comunidade e aprendi a respeitar
essa comunidade e trabalhar pra ela
com esta pessoa
esta pessoa enviuvou muito cedo com
tripa e 50 anos
como vou fazer faz hoje exatamente 39
anos e sempre conhecido preto mas sempre
acontece com sorriso nos lábios e sei
que essa felicidade sociedade de vinha
do contato com o combinado do trabalho
para fazer com os outros e foi com ela
que eu aprendi a ser feliz provocando
alguma felicidade nos outros acho que
talvez das lições mais importantes que
podemos aprender com com estas pessoas
resumidamente cria desafios destas
pessoas
nesta mensagem final que é um clássico a
frase de um filósofo grego que diz que
há três tipos dólar - são vivos mortos e
os que andam no mar é uma forma nós os
reinos valorizarmos essa experiência
estranha de passarmos os dias sobre um
maio que não respeitam totalmente mas eu
queria dizer vos que pra mim também há
três tipos de mulheres as vivas as
mortas e aquelas que não salvo do mar
para quem vive perto viu como eu é
absolutamente necessário e relevante
obrigado
[Aplausos]